all right nate thanks a million speaking
of summer we're checking in with
lifestyle expert ali levine for some
must-have summer hacks
for the family first i have the
incredible growing
brilliant it is a online preschool
academy
that is live classes can i just tell you
when i found
live classes for my toddler i was so
excited because
i've done other classes where you know
it's a lot replays and they get to check
things out and have lessons but there's
no interaction
this academy growing brilliant there's
so much attraction there are kids that
are engaging that are there online with
you you schedule a 45 minute class
you're able to have teachers speaking
with you they're world-renowned teachers
they teach over 60 subjects stem
learning as well
they're really all about our little ones
thriving and it's two to six years old
as far as the ages
once you're signed up and you are a
student at growing brilliant
you're good to go all you need is wi-fi
your computer
ipad whatever it may be wi-fi and your
little one and that's it
they're there for 45 minutes engaged and
they're taken care of
with their incredible teacher to have
fun lessons to thrive and learn and
interact with other kids
check out growingbrillian.com and if you
use my code ally in all caps
before july 30th you will get one week
for free to enroll your little ones you
can check it all out
experience the magic as well and then
sign them up so check out
growingbrillian.com
next i have the amazing instasteen okay
i have to tell you do you see that
sticker that's my face
i was so excited to partner with
instasteem because i think their product
is just it's mind-boggling to me that
this wasn't out there before this is the
first of its kind like in the world
instasteem is a hands-free
electricity free electricity free
steamer so you don't have to worry about
going to the dry
cleaner you don't have to worry about
having an actual steamer being a stylist
and a mom
like i can't tell you how much i think
this is so incredible because it's hard
to get ready right i mean it's hard for
me to get ready as a busy mom on the go
and i love that instasteem makes it so
easy for you they have individual
garment bags where you stick your
clothing in you stick your linens you
got the little pods
and you go ahead and are able to clean
them up and refresh them so check out
instasteempod.com
use my code ali20 on any other projects
and you'll be able to
check them out i highly recommend last
but not least i want to share little
ones with you
this video will share everything about
their amazing app and their website
and little ones is all about helping you
have a sleep and nutritional program
let's be real as adults if we don't get
enough sleep we're gonna have to eat
we're not happy
we can't show up with our best selves we
can't expect our kids to feel any
different right they have meltdowns
they're overtired they're hangry they're
all over the place
and it's hard them to enjoy anything for
them and us so
little ones wants to take care of you
and help you take care of
just that you don't have to worry about
it anymore you put in your
kids family schedule they help you
decide hey this is what they need to eat
they help you send notifications like
god said when i get notifications on my
phone it's like oh and it is nap time
i forgot i'm a busy day oh it's harley's
wake time oh it's time to feed this
they help you with all that and if you
have an off day you can troubleshoot
with them and they have real live people
they have world-renowned sleep
consultants pediatricians recommend
and they've got you know experts of
parents a whole village for you
on this app on this website so everyone
needs a village right especially
nowadays
and it's right there for you so they can
help you troubleshoot you never feel
alone and you're taken care of and i
just think it's brilliant
and it's everywhere from newborn to five
years old so you are taken care of
literally from birth
to when they're a little bit older so
that you can figure it all out and you
don't feel alone which a lot of parents
especially nowadays
do i know it was really overwhelming for
me as a new mom so i was really excited
about little ones
for all my parents to be able to
experience this so check out
littleones.com
to check out their nutritional and sleep
program
i hope these hacks help all of you enjoy
your summer even more
happy summer and if you want to follow
me my social is at ali living design
and my website alibibean.com where you
can learn more about these incredible
products as well as anything you want to
know about me
thanks so much for having me